it's not my free act if I throw a coin
up and set head tail or what no that's
contingency freedom is a necessity of
its
[Music]
own you've said that recently things
have changed with ideology that you were
saying until now ideology was just a lie
but now it's a it's more cynical thing
in a very precise sense that you know
what you're doing I would call in the GU
of truth but what does this do then to
the old Enlightenment mind this idea
that everyone is a kind of which you've
written about as well that we're sort of
rational actors and we can make these
decisions if you're in this kind of
total par no I I remain fully although
many people would not believe me a guy
of Enlightenment I I my I what I'm
saying is not that since rational
argumentation doesn't work then whatever
just violence or do nothing and so on no
I think that there are different even
strategies of speaking where you can
undermine this uh stance and I even in
one of my earlier books I forgot which
one there are too many of them I
elaborated this how you know uh
every apparently cynical Guy usually you
have a fetish an exception you know and
there is where you have to attach it
maybe some of you know this example that
I used years ago it's real life very
stupid a a friend of mine which was 30
years ago 20 had a wife who was sorry
for this sexist sounding but beautiful
young they loved each other all you want
and then all of a sudden in her mid 20s
she got breast cancer and it was too
late she died in two months horrible and
we were so surprised surprised that the
guy the husband just went on functioning
like normally talked even about the last
moments of his wife and then uh
something happened his wife has had a uh
uh Preferred Pet object a small hamster
half a year later his hamster this
hamster died the guy immediately tried
to kill you know hamster was his fetish
he eat embodied like the wife somehow as
a fetish it was a disal of his wife's
death so it was at that point that he
totally broke down he had to be for one
month on how to call it suicide watch
you know always somebody with him or and
tomorrow to make a little bit of
propaganda at my uh uh at my uh uh uh
speech about Surplus enjoyment or maybe
even at the theological debate in the
afternoon I will go into another form of
this I was so
fascinated with uh the figure of uh
Hinrich himler uh SS boss who was
formally formally as to form an
extremely ethical guy never hurt but he
organized Holocaust but for him this was
the highest ethical act and you know he
used a terrifying reversal here this
cynicism at its purest uh he admitted it
this is horrible how can we decent
Germans do this killing Jewish children
uh women not even AR and remain decent
you know what was his answer Oriental
spiritualism he always was carrying in
his uh uh in his pock pocket a special
leathered copy of Bhagavad Gita where
you have this idea you know the king is
convinced to go into battle saying life
is an appearance the main thing is to do
your D and the really horrible thing you
find the same rhetorical trick in
stalinism with Trump today it's uh we
all have as I used it in my example you
know this I call it basic Common Sense
decency like certain thing you may I
don't dream about them I'm not saying I
don't have dirty dreams just not that
kind but but that's not part of the life
conversation what I don't don't be
afraid no no no what I just wanted to
say is that uh uh uh can I very briefly
very briefly really the problem of
himler is how do you remain saying and
so on and he operates a very dirty trick
he says that every idot can be decent
and fight for his countries but true
patriotism it is that you are ready to
do horrible things for your country and
I discovered in how they were making
propaganda for collectivization in 193s
early 30s when they collectivized and
millions died of hunger in Russia and I
found the same figure they said you will
see horrible things peasant Farmers
Family starving and so on but this de
your decency is the greatest uh
temptation to evil if you're a true
bolic you go on
killing and this horrible ethics is
returning to David Trump but not yes yes
I want to ask you a bit in terms of
appearances as well that we take for
realities and I was thinking about um
Hegel in a wide brain where you're
talking all about Hegel and subjectivity
and how hegelian Notions of subjectivity
might relate to this kind of Strange
World we're now in where for the first
time you know the Russians wanted to do
this in the Soviet Union but now we
actually begin to have this technology
where we can create these um you know
strange singularities where which you
write about where brain computer
interfaces can link brains into this
potentially of course it's still sci-fi
but the beginnings of these kinds of
Technologies and I want to ask you about
that how then does that change to you
the notion first of subjectivity which
you write about and also these ideas of
free will
autonomy in terms of who's controlling
the brain I don't want to lose too much
time so as to freedom I try to provide
in the first chapter of my freedom book
which will be out yes by Bloomsbury in
the fall I try to how the point is how
to in facing the the neuro
neurobiological however call it
determinism how to under quotation marks
save freedom yes because I agree with
some determinist like the German lady
Sab Helder she's very intelligent she
said that she even doesn't argue she
said that the moment you accept
naturalism there simply is no space for
freedom freedom is a subjective concept
is so how to save Freedom my answer is
not that it's Freedom already there in
nature but that the first thing to do is
to open up nature not in the sense of
higher spirituality but in the sense
that nature is in itself ontologically
incomplete open not only human sorry not
only human culture but nature what do I
mean by ontological openness for example
here I always opposed historicism which
says for example classical example I use
it often in books to to really
understand Shakespeare you have to know
the details of Elizabeth in England and
so on my idea is not to really
understand sh Shakespeare didn't
understand himself his work was full of
inconsistencies incomplete and if you
come later it's not a an obstacle you
can even understand sexp better than he
understood himself and uh uh so in some
sense we are not just uh reading
Shakespeare differently we are literally
completing his work that's how I I hate
the official dogma of multiculturalism
but I respect it when you really get it
for example maybe some of you heard this
I find it so wonderful that the best
Shakespeare Cinema version that I know
is done by Akira kurava 61 or two the
version of Hamlet setting in
contemporary Japan Hamlet is a Japanese
student returning from the United States
his father was a big corporate boss but
uh uh uh it and it has a wonderful title
this movie only bad people sleep well
it's a wonderful title they don't care
but what I want to say is that uh I am
ready maybe I'm speculating too much I'm
now trying to study in detail as much as
I can understand quantum physics because
I think what you find at the bottom of
quantum physics is this idea of income
ontologically incomplete Universe in the
sense that in what sense sorry give me
two minutes it's it's an old story but I
like to repeat it of mine uh you know
because it links to the previous debate
uh uh video games look the first thing
about video games is that their universe
is incomplete you're in a game stupid
game where you are shooting fighting on
the Main Street of a small town let us
say and in the back you see forest with
trees but it's not part of the game that
you can approach those trees and see
them in detail it's part of the game
that you cannot go there so the
programmer say why lose time on that
programming let's leave it open and the
way I got this from a popular
introduction to philosophy sorry forgot
that name but very intelligently I think
written the guy says uh is not quantum
physics does it not have the same lesson
when God was programming the universe he
said people are too stupid to reach
beyond the atom so why should I bother
their programming he lived it
undetermined and we were a little bit
too bright for God and we as you say in
English C got with his pants down as it
were you know and do you believe then or
are you positing in terms of that
argument so is the are you saying or
maybe it's not possible within quantum
physics this question um is reality
discreet or continuous so is reality
like Minecraft where you kind of zoom in
further and further and further and then
you get as you say down further further
to these tiny little you know to the
leptons and further and further down is
that a that Sye spontaneously but I
don't have any empirical ground for this
I am for discret nature in what sense
and I think this is almost maybe the
lesson of quantum physics but I'm very
much speculating now I think that it's
not this endless divisibility you can
further split the at certain point you
can come to the you I can split this in
half this and that this and that but I
believe when you approach the zero point
the division is between something and
nothing you see you get something its
Counterpoint is void is nothing and uh
so I'm not saying this is bad
metaphysical reading of that in this
freedom is grounded no First Freedom is
not
contingency know it's not my free act if
I but even this is not of course it's
deterministic but let's say for me it's
a contingency if to make a decision I
throw a coin up and said head tail or
what no that's contingency from my view
really it's not but freedom is a
necessity of its own freedom is a
positive decision that you do is this
only as they say users illusion I think
not I think we have to it's more
important than ever we have to accept
this ontological openness of nature
already of history for example we are
now in an open situation and
retroactively it will become necessary
if there will be a World
War if there will be people who will
survive it they will tell the story of
how it was all pointed towards this war
it's we were doomed if there will not be
a war they will say it was like cold war
false alarms and so on what I'm claiming
is that these are not simply Illusions
the situation is genuinely open and
another lesson which I I know it's not
legit imate I apply it too quickly from
quantum physics to humanist nonetheless
is that to understand something a
historical event you should read it as a
super with in a superposition with other
possible events when
something happens you should always ask
yourself what other options failed so
that this could have happened so in in
this way back to your point immediately
uh my point in wire brain is a more
optimistic one it's not just dark end of
humanity I try to and it's so
interesting that nobody likes those
final concluding chapter where I try to
do uh exactly this to ask this
absolutely naive question maybe it's
even a wrong question let's say that
this self objectivization in the sense
of a machine which can read our mind
let's say that it more or less
succeeds we have it does this mean that
we no longer exist as subjects my answer
is an optimist one there
first by subject we should not
understand this inner wealth of
personality but the pure cartisian
subjectivity that empty space will
remain supported in what in the
unconscious to continue watching this
video click the link in the top left or
in the description below or visit I.V
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest
ideas